Okay, so thus far, we've seen how inheritance
can help us with reusing instance variables. Now I
want to show you an example of how inheritance
can help with reusing methods. So here we are
back at the code, where we have a class
called Parent and a class called Child. And if
you recall, class Child inherits from class Parent. Now,
I'll begin by defining a simple instance method inside
class Parent. And I will call it show_info.
The first argument of this method is self, and
all this method does is it prints out the last name and eye color of the parent.
All right, there are the two print statements.
Now to test to see if this method actually
works, I'm going to call this method show_info
using the parent's instance billy_cyrus. So let me do
that next. So there is that method. Now all I've done thus far is created a new
method called show_info inside class Parent. And then
used an instance of class Parent, instance called billy_cyrus
to call that method. Now to be able to focus on this statement's output, I am
going to comment out the other instance statement for now. There. Let
me go ahead and save and run this program. Alright. So the program prints
out the correct values of billy_cyrus' last name and eye color. So far so good.